qui est bas la voyait en moi un tiers
d'entre nous l'acceptons les balades au
web on écoute et on est malade
aujourd'hui on va pas faire des
activités manuelles parce que je vais le
décès d un bon qu'on définit l'activité
s'est vite m'ont écouté ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas faire dix raids
reddit qui parle pas d'un truc que vous
dire bah comme le délire de la mer ou
des océans la dernière fois cette fois
c'est gratos n'y a pas de lien avec une
passion un truc qui attise la curiosité
dans la vraie vie c'est juste des vidéos
qui sont extrêmement amusant se seraient
dit s'appelle watch people die inside
regardez les gens mourir de l'intérieur
c'est les vidéos dans lesquelles
quelqu'un a une réaction qui veut tout
dire sur ce qu'il ressent le langage
corporel transmet tellement de choses
dans notre avenir week end ses mémoires
que du coup j'adore ça m'aurait dit
parce que on comprend facilement ce
qu'on voit et surtout ce qu'on voit
c'est spontané du coup moi ça fait
chialer derrière j'ai saxo fera beaucoup
mieux aussi mais avant tout d'être
alors donc ça ça m'est arrivé
aujourd'hui à bout quoi donc au nom à la
pause à chaque fois qu'un serveur passe
avec autant de verres sur un plat ça me
stresse pour cette raison qui est
probablement arrivé à ce gars vu qu'il
est sûr c'est au brésil à aa
voilà ça que j'aime rien n'est sûr jouer
rires des calculs et le langage corporel
dans ce timing l'âme ne ment pas et
j'adore succulent l'un des meilleurs
cocktails de la vie bon la chaîne vidéo
elle est un peu complexe je vous remet
dans le contexte parce que comme ça dès
votre premier visionnage vous allez
kiffer le gars qu'on voit à droite dans
la boîte et pour faire sa demande
d'invitation au bal de fin d'année à son
ami ici à gauche dans la vidéo il a
planté n'est pas de tous les jeux ne
sais pas combien de mètres sur le bord
de la route et sur chaque panneau il ya
un mot et tous ces mobiles bout à bout
forment la phrase suivante lille will
you go to the promised by ou un truc
genre quoi c'est sa demande d'invitation
pour le bal imaginez la pierre actions
possibles de la bof
voilà et bien vous allez voir c'est pire
c'est pire que ce que vous ne l'imaginez
m
[Musique]
le bec a eu l'idée est à côté de toi
dans cette voiture et il a fait ça pour
toi tu viens naturellement de dire que
c'est une idée de merde
rien ne pourra jamais rattraper ça
[Musique]
ol a naturellement dix ans que son avis
soit biaisée par le fait que le gars qui
a fait ça c'est le gars sûr qu'elle
accroche
elle a naturellement dit que c'était une
idée de merde rien de pouvoir trop plus
là c'est chiant ce futur couple c'est
chaud du coin ce mach aller parce
qu'elle réalise qu'elle a dû blessés en
plein coeur son cher et tendre être
aimée elle pourra rien n'y fait elle
pour acheter autant de pansements et
d'antiseptiques qu'elle veut c'est trop
tard regardez sur quoi flammèches
y at il un signe de détresse plus grand
que celui là c'est horrible c'est la
pire situation a le silence personne ne
sait quoi dire
c'est horrible c'est quoi j'espère
qu'ils soient nos bals de fin d'année
ans et que ces 10 $ bobo la voix c'était
il ya six ans et depuis ils ont emménagé
ensemble kaki son trésor c'est ce que
j'espère est ce que c'est arrivé
vous savez au buzz aldrin qui réagit un
discours de trump sur l'espace buzz
aldrin c'est le deuxième homme à avoir
marché sur la lune parce qu'il est
descendu de la navette en deuxième il
connaît un peu le game attention
l'achat d'or j'adore anges elle est
belle c'est une très belle
haha ça le démange même pu regarder
regardez son langage qui arrive où il se
décale il a honte à ça me glace le sang
plutôt vers une perte dévastatrice au
lot n'était pas au bout de tes paix mon
ami c'est génial là un film est la
réaction de quelqu'un qu'il découvre ce
que c'est que les taxes quand tu es
innocent et que tu comprends pas
pourquoi il ya des taxes pourquoi ça
existe c'est que ça te brusque qu'au
début c'est drôle à ce moment là elle a
réalisé à quel point elle déteste son
job
[Musique]
oh non non y at il une petite fille très
bon tu la retrouves s'il te plaît
commenté le boss pour y trouver des
trucs dont je parle il ya un juif comme
ça oui je dis juste et bon d'une petite
fille comme ça et qui a deux petites
dents et qui regardent en quoi la caméra
est à l'exact sur la réaction de cette
femme je suis chez les femmes c'est la
petite fille du jpk grandi et lui avait
fait un truc bizarre elle et sa vie
c'est que de refaire cette réaction en
boucle et en boucle et en boucle la
différence d'âge ça veut rien dire ce
que je veux dire c'est bon tu tiens le
coup frérot elle le vaut elle est
mignonne
tu peux y arriver
[Musique]
ah ah ce que tu es prêt à endurer quand
même c'est fou dont il est tellement
dans le mal dit lui frérot n'y a aucune
honte à sub de faire partie de la
confrérie des faibles physiquement les
parents de toc jamais à ça c'est vrai
[ __ ] mec
[Musique]
au assez génial il fut mais il n'a pas
le droit
donc il doit garder la fumée devant un
verre mais la belle a le recul il l'a
filmé pour qu'elle soit mal à [ __ ] il
est malin il a fumé avec sont elles pour
qu'elles se bat qu'elle se dise normes
le film pas tellement ce mardi frérot
y'a plus qu'à être encore plus smart
pour arrêter de fumer maintenant
[Musique]
toi face à ce qui te fait réaliser que
tu as vieillis tu es tu n'est plus tout
jeune que tu n'as plus ce corps que tu
n'as plus cette énergie on va tous finir
comme ça et tout ce qu'on rit en voyant
ça sachez que ça vous arrivera avant les
autres ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mec
le vent est tellement conséquent qu'il
ya plusieurs sites elle revoit dans son
verre pour l'esquivé elle pousse son
verre et ce même le plus de nos
possibles à lui et elle s'échappe par le
dessous de son bras et lui face à ça il
fait mine de ne rien ressentir de s'en
sortir indemne la tête haute mais il va
être complexé pendant au moins une
dizaine d'années c'est trop puissant la
lega voilà pourquoi on ne veut pas faire
les gros faire ça parce que ça les meufs
si elles sont pas intéressées elles sont
pas intéressés c'est bon si c'est non
c'est non c'est bon donc quand vous
forcez comme lui déjà vous mettez
l'autre personne dans l'embarras de
fouet en plus votre ego mec est terminée
à vie en bois aux horribles au sel elle
va donner chaud mais the man behind
[Musique]
où
batta quel code non je fais que pour
rire cela le sait le seul à l'avoir vécu
premier degré beaucoup de déception ah
ok sans mode l'art dans la bouche
oh non non elles entendent remettre en
question tous les décennies de mariage
la nuit de noce l'enfant tout alors
qu'il se fait plus qu il avait une
petite vidéo sur twitter qui lui a plu
il a voulu refaire la même forme c'est
pas grave quoi allumer les vilaines
c'est quoi sa préférée oh oui oui la
british et à un sourire à travers la
douleur
non elle n'est pas que ces dominos
annoncé tout comme aux non attention à
ça vous a fait mal là non il va rater
dix mille dominos ya apparemment là au
nom
[Musique]
sa réaction elle est belle au final
c'est bien c'est mieux que ce soit passé
comme ça et qu'on ait vu envisage d'une
telle bienveillance et d'intel bah c'est
pas grave tant pis on devra essayer
quelle gentillesse le moment où j'ai
réalisé que le vase ne pouvait pas être
sauvé hausse et de la poterie j'aimerais
trop faire une vidéo activités manuelles
avec de la poterie avec ce truc là vous
êtes chauds ou pas qui est chaud bon je
n'arrive pas à comprendre à quel point
ces forêts parce que je connais rien à
la poterie mais c'est impressionnant
tout cas moi aussi je veux faire un vase
annonce hc servette elles montrent un
puzzle et tout va se défaire parce qu'il
va trop le punch est en avance et que le
mec avec ses spaghettis vidéo qui
aggravent tournée là où ils montent sont
pas sur le cas mais il penche trop en
avant attention on va vivre linverse de
la satisfaction c'est maintenant on
reste là bah oui bah oui mais au moins
tu fera pas l'erreur
ces petites phrases la désagréable que
t'as pas du tout envie d'entendre qu'on
est avec sapins au moins tu reprends pas
les ja c'est ce que le bcsq ah mais non
il va être déçu puisqu'il va pas
s'arrêter
je le sens
[Musique]
il est bel et bien partie sa de regarder
l'autre côté pado ça me fait quelque
chose là ça me fait quelque chose comme
des la chaussure va se bloquer aussi si
la chaussée ce blog c'est olalalala la
deuxième se bloque la deuxième se bloque
ok les récupérer
ok l'honorable au quai dillon reste qu'à
l'habitude
[Musique]
la deuxième se bloque c'est comme ça que
ça doit se tenir la deuxième ce bloc et
on se lève tous pour un peu d'air pour
les amis qu'est-ce qu'il ya personne
vers la porte
avais tu commences à me faire peur vient
plutôt faible ou trop et bien les amis
c'est la fin de ce vrai dit fabuleux et
encore il en reste beaucoup alors je
vous mettrais bien dans la description
n'hésitez pas à passer voir moi je les
ai passés par toque de tous les temps
mais y'en a beaucoup il est souvent
accusé il ya souvent des trucs
incroyables je vous ai trouvés dans une
prochaine vidéo il y en a un qui est
radtke rentrer allez je parle comme je
suis venu à très vite c'est chaud
[Musique]